there is a crazy flu going around lots
of
miserable dehydrated people with high
fevers and diarrhea
and one of those dehydrated high fevered
miserable people is april who hates me
i want another nurse well there are none
we're stretched pretty thin right now
then i want a janitor they can do what
you do right yep
nurses and janitors are totally
interchangeable except no one dresses up
like a janitor when they want to be
[ __ ]
i get the sense that maybe you're angry
at me for kissing andy
no i'm not what are you talking about
that's crazy and that you think it might
be fun to take it out on me
please don't do that do i can't do
anything
i'm sick
[Music]
my blankets are on the floor
[Music]
rent to swag shareholders as you can see
your store
is hopping these kids are renting my old
clothes like they're going out of style
which they never will yeah that's a lot
of foot traffic tommy i like it
oh diam it is kind of a sausage party in
here
for the record would hit it would hit
woodhut hard pass tom
who is this person this is mona lisa
saperstein my new sales associate
mona lisa saperstein
does that mean oh yeah she's my sister
my twin sister from the same mystery
thank you so much for hiring mona lisa
it means so much to me
even though honestly she's the worst
she is the worst person in the world
huge skank terrible but thank you
it means a lot of course gotta keep it
in the family yeah but does it have to
be this family
actually that reminds me boss man i need
to leave early today because my
shrink got me and him tickets to a pit
bull concert
and i already committed to that and so
if you say that i can't go it's like
you're taking something away from me
um store's really busy i need you to
stay i totally hear you
um i also don't like what you're saying
so if you say no
i will start a fire in the bathroom
okay i guess you can go yeah i know i
can what did i tell you huh
the words
she's the worst in the world john
ralphio how are you
quality welders
that how did how did you do this called
in a few favors
excuse me a few hundred favors mr vice
president
ben wyatt from congressman murray's
office and dave told me you're gonna be
coming by and you must be leslie knope
welcome
welcome
my my name just came out of your mouth
well yeah it did
this isn't happening this this isn't
real no it's it's happening and i'm
delighted to have you here on behalf of
the president myself
oh mr vice president i am deeply
flattered but there's no way that i
could take over madam secretary
clinton's position
i mean i'm confident you could do that
job or any other but okay
well the reason you're here is i'm told
you've done such a great job
in your town and the state of indiana
and i just want to say congratulations
for your public service
i just want to say thank you well you
you are very welcome you're very welcome
hey you're you're very welcome you're
you're very handsome i think we're all
done
thank you very much thank you very much
we'll see you tomorrow well
you will thank you mr vice president
you're welcome you don't let anything
happen to him do you understand me
he is precious cargo
hey ladies and gentlemen for the first
time ever in her new part-time job in
the public health department at city
halls and meredith perkins yay
oh leslie this is so nice i put
poisonous gas in one of these balloons
so if any of them pops you may die
no april we would all die gases
fill the volume of whatever container
they're in
school we have activities every hour on
your first day 10 a.m anne's first day
waffle explosion
11 a.m the start paperwork jamboree and
then 12 noon
sharp is the inaugural d ants party
welcome to city hall cupcake how many of
you are in here
there's seven and you have an office
mate his name is stuart and he's kind of
a grouch
i have an office mate get these balloons
out of here
hi i'm ann gentlemen wilderness weekend
is upon us there will be no video games
there will be no internet pads this
weekend you have two parents
me and mother nature and i
am mother nature's brother brother
nature
but you can call me andy or brother
nature
your call thank you andy brother nature
for the last three years i have served
as troop leader of the pawnee rangers
this is our handbook
i wrote the whole thing myself okay it's
time to give out the badges
um let's see emily you get the badge for
most community
to service the best penguin blog
to abigail fly his hairstyle
and ann gets the match for second fliest
hairstyle oh
i wasn't competing for that i'll say
five years ago a plucky fifth grader
wanted to join the pawnee rangers
but their executive council said what
obnoxious jerks always say
no this is males only go start your own
club
she couldn't so i did we're called the
pawnee goddesses and we're freaking
awesome
hey ron whose club do you think is
better yours your mind
the answer is mine say mine is better
it's not a competition
oh but it is your club made it a
competition when they kept girls out
oh my stars i'm just a little lady my
fragile constitution cannot handle the
fierce amount doers
i have no problem with strong women
leslie who's leslie
my name is annabelle vandergraff and
y'all i just fall to pieces when
the sun shines on my head however
the pawnee rangers were founded because
some boys want to go out into nature
and learn traditional survival skills
without being distracted by girls
well my awesome goddesses don't want to
be distracted by losers
say my club is better ron say it my club
is better
say it come on say it there say it
say it's better say my club is better
say it give it up whose club is better
mine say it you know it
say it on principle i never say anything
that another person is obviously trying
to get me to say
my first wedding ceremony took two hours
because after the priest said repeat
after me
i fell silent
i'm gonna get 12 eggs and part of a dead
animal
dealer's choice please and thank you
what can i get you in i will have
oatmeal and berries and i will have
catfish and grits with pumpernickel
toast
explain well instead of getting swept up
in my boyfriend's personalities i'm
dating myself
and trying new things so every time i go
out to eat i
order one thing that's typical me and
then something that i would never order
now i have two best friends ann and ann
each one more beautiful than the other
oh i also have been documenting all the
new things i'm trying on my blog
check this out i went skydiving
which anne is screaming like a maniac
oatmeal anne or
catfish anne i'm not sure because i
instantly blacked out from extreme
terror
mr haverford on the morning of your
crash were you alone in your car yes
your honor this was an accident plain
and simple i don't want to put words in
your mouth
but case dismissed and you were texting
at the time correct
how dare you sir i was tweeting please
read exhibit c
the transcript of your twitter page
leading up to and immediately following
your crash
9 15. four green lights in a row hashtag
blessed 917
drive faster blue civic damn hashtag
soccer moms 918. gotta pass this lady on
the edge
that's when i hit the fire hydrant sorry
allegedly
hit the fire hydrant 920 just hit a fire
hydrant but i survived
hashtag unbreakable hashtag what's mr
glass up to these days
hashtag why no sequel prosecution rest
your honor
mr haverford you have a problem keeping
your eyes on the road and off your
electronic devices
i'm gonna tailor a punishment to fit the
crime
one week without screens no phone
tablets computers television
anything no please send me to jail any
slip-ups and that week becomes a month
turn in your phone please
fine one last tweet bailiff
press send bailiff press send hey bro
listen i was trying to buy this
handcrafted mahogany wood model of
b25 mitchell panchito aircraft for me
don't sass me and i went to this website
and this ad popped up that said
hey ron swanson check out this great
offer
what's your question my question is what
the hell
like how do they know who you are yeah
okay
um there are these things called cookies
where like if you go to a site and buy
something it'll remember you and then
create
ads for other stuff you might want to
buy so it learns
information about me seems like an
invasion of privacy
dude if you think that's bad go to
google earth and type in your address
you